اعزائي المشاهدين هنالك العديد من البرامج
للتعرف على الوجه منها تطبيق برمجي
للقياسات الحيويه بيومتريك للتحقق من هويه
الشخص
ورغم ما تثيره هذه التقنيه من انتقادات
بشان الخصوصيه فان التطبيقات التجاريه
والحكوميه لها هي في توسع مستمر
فمثلا حكومه كوريا الجنوبيه اختبرت تقنيه
التعرف على الوجه لتتبع حالات الاصابه
بفيروس كورونا وتخفيف العبء على العاملين
في المجال الصحي
بينما اعلن مكتب مفوض المعلومات في
بريطانيا عن فرض غرامه على شركه تكنولوجيا
التعرف على الوجه بقيمه تصل الى 20 مليون
دولار لخرقها قوانين حمايه البيانات في
المملكه المتحده اما شركه كليرفيو او كلير
فيو فاعلنت عن دعمها لمنظمات انفاذ
القانون في الوصول الى المطلوبين وتحديد
هوياتهم وذلك من خلال اكبر قاعده بيانات
معروفه تضم اكثر من عشره مليارات صوره وجه
مصدرها وسائل الاعلام الاخباريه ومواقع
ماتشات ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي العامه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات